l'Assemblée nationale peut-elle remettre
en cause la réforme des retraites une
nouvelle bataille s'engage première
étape ce matin les députés examinent une
proposition de loi qui prévoit de
ramener la retraite de 64 à 62 ans
au cours de cette discussion
préparatoire en commission le
rassemblement national et la nupond
défendu le retour aux 62 ans cette
proposition de loi est de salubrité
publique
hey je suis l'axe s'il vous plaît un peu
de calme c'est quand même moi qui
préside cette séance vous voulez faire
le boxon si on pouvait s'écouter qu'il y
a un peu de calme non non mais c'est moi
qui donne la parole c'est moi qui
préside vous la voulez pas je vous la
donne pas c'est moi qui préside pas la
peine de dire que vous avez un bel
organe vocal j'en ai un aussi bon alors
voilà je peux crier moi aussi c'est
clair hein d'accord après 2 heures de
débat la majorité avec le concours de
députés LR fait bloc lors du vote de
l'article 1er visant à rétablir l'âge de
départ à la retraite à 62 ans les
amendements de suppression sont adoptés
en conséquence l'article 1er et
supprimer l'opposition dépose
immédiatement des centaines de
sous-amendement objectif faire durer les
débats et empêcher le vote du texte qui
serait alors examiné dans sa version
originelle dans l'hémicycle j'ai donné
dans le showby ça va depuis des années
le théâtre la musique tout ça donc là
voilà mais curieusement
dès que vous êtes à la retraite on vous
veut
non c'est vrai dis-moi qu'on a plus
envie c'est là que les gens vous
appellent ils disent mais non je te jure
il faut venir c'est fini et plus on dit
non et plus les gens vous vole j'invite
toute seule et ceux qui le peuvent à
venir massivement le 6 juin redire que
nous ne courberons pas la tête nous ne
courberons pas les Chine à la reprise en
début d'après-midi la gauche quitte la
salle nous partons
la parole sans opposition l'examen du
texte devient une formalité il est
adopté amputé de son article fin ce sera
le 8 juin quand la proposition de loi
sera débattue dans l'émission la
deuxième étape devrait alors se jouer la
présidente de l'Assemblée pourrait
remettre en avant le coût de la mesure
avec
l'irrecevabilité financière c'est
l'article 40 il y a aucun doute sur les
recevabilité financières cette
proposition de loi et cette article 1 et
clairement une charge une dépense et les
parlementaires ne peuvent pas engager
des dépenses
démocratie comprenez notre colère
comprenez notre colère déni de
démocratie ou obstruction c'est selon ce
bruit et cette fureur ne convienne pas
la démocratie française c'est ça toute
leur stratégie empêcher les
représentants du pape de se prononcer si
effectivement il n'y a pas de vote une
troisième étape pourrait se dessiner
Charles de Courson envisage une motion
de censure contre le gouvernement la
nu-plavoterait le rassemblement national
ne s'est pas encore prononcé au cinéma
il y a pas de retraite pour les
comédiens un avantage de lire c'est que
il y a de plus en plus de rôles bah il y
a plus de rôles parce que c'est horrible
mais il y a moins d'acteurs
donc pour faire des rôles de gens plus
âgés
si tu veux des gens connus il y en a
moins que
ça
sur le référendum sur l'immigration sur
la possibilité de déroger à la primauté
du droit européen vous êtes d'accord
avec eux d'abord je trouve que la photo
est très belle
les tous méfris ont pris un coup de
vieux mais non je plaisante ça c'était
parce qu'ils ont été aimable avec moi le
combat contre l'extrême droite ne passe
plus par des arguments moraux il faut
décrédibiliser le RN par le fond et les
incohérences plutôt que par des mots des
années 90 qui ne fonctionnent plus
depuis plusieurs semaines le chef de
l'État montre parfois son agacement par
rapport à la première ministre est-ce
que ça vaut la peine de couper des
arbres ça qui permettent d'avoir une
fraîcheur bienveillante dans la ville de
faire baisser la température pour tout
le monde et qui abrite aussi des espèces
protégées c'est l'âme de Vichy les
arbres avec ses magnifiques
constructions thermales c'est un
ensemble qui fait partie du cœur de
Vichy faut pas détruire ça c'est
précieux les vacances ont disparu aussi
rien à bouger derrière la moustache dans
la tête
régulariser des immigrés on parle bien
de clandestins ça crée un appel d'air
l'immigration à un coup le coup lié au
regroupement familial vous mettez deux
trois gouttes d'huile essentielle pour
qu'en fait c'est une petite odeur en
fait ils sont dans l'âge de la pensée
magique donc ce qui compte c'est pas de
dire non les monstres n'existe pas non
les loups sont dans les forêts de dire
je vois que tu as très très peur qui
vient de te voir regarde on va mettre le
petit magique vous faites trois petites
le soir comme ça l'odeur les loups ne
l'aime pas du tout il ne viendront pas
dans ta chambre et moi je suis fatigué
moi je me sens insulté quand on traite
d'extrême droite je me sens insulté
parce que à partir d'extrême droite ces
humours Zemmour j'ai été très fier quand
Marine Le Pen elle a dit qu'il serait
pas Premier ministre et qu'il serait pas
dans son gouvernement parce que moi si
c'était le cas j'aurais pas voté le poil
au deuxième tour ça aurait été hors de
question ça a été fondé par Pierre
Bousquet qui était à ma famille SS point
voilà on a voilà
voilà vous l'aurez compris on a juste un
peu juste un petit souci de de son et ce
ne sera jamais la mienne parce que moi
mon combat restera celui des idéaux et
des convictions au service de la région
et des Franciliens bien envoyés j'étire
mon micro il est paniqué par je range
mes feuilles voilà faut pas me la faire
à moi
[Rires]
vous avez cela met Timothée vous avez
essayé j'ai essayé mais
vous aviez des bonbons
non je pense que j'aurais buté un peu
sur des
c'est bizarre comme phrase
[Rires]
[Musique]
vous pouvez continuer ça me plaît
beaucoup
[Rires]
de plateau d'hier et bien Axel est-ce
que vous pouvez entourer un personnage
que vous voulez supprimer de la photo
loin des pelouse Eric Cantona donne
aussi de la voix cette fois pour la
sortie de ses propres chansons ce
vendredi tu me diras et the friends
willost sur son compte Instagram
l'ancien attaquant de 57 ans on a
dévoilé un extrait
de footballeurs à comédien en passant
par écrivain photographe ou encore
producteur en plus de multiplier les
casquettes Eric Cantona et partout
notamment sur Netflix à la fiche Daka le
film français le plus visionné dans le
monde en Pologne ils ont pris une de mes
chansons pour les Kinder Bueno que les
chocolats
et donc envoyer une fille très jolie
avec son Kinder Bueno ça peut obscène
alors elle est là
[Musique]
vous connaissez le dicton si c'est
gratuit
et vous le produit exactement
pas encore en France mais ça va sûrement
arriver en France donc elle est gratuite
c'est une télé 4K donc haute définition
55 pouces en gros écouterait 1000 euros
normalement mais là vous ne payez ouais
c'est quand même pas mal elle ne coûte
rien mais mais mais le petit truc c'est
que vous allez être soumis à de la
publicité et il y a une phrase de que
j'avais lu de Monsieur contes Sponville
que j'appelais que j'adore quand on dit
j'aime le poulet c'est pas forcément bon
pour le poulet et je citer régulièrement
cette phrase parce que les parents mais
je fais ça parce que je t'aime ou alors
la femme ou l'homme qui dit ah ça va
mais je fais ça parce que je t'aime
d'accord mais quand on dit j'aime le
poulet c'est pas forcément bon pour le
poulet